citizens of the reject Nation we are
here for the final episode of season
three of The Witcher Volume 2 Henry
cavill's last hurray as Gary Rivers the
titular Witcher Greg how you feeling I'm
good John I'm excited for uh Henry
Cavill to hopefully get proper residuals
off of this while Netflix is raking in
all that dough you know before they take
it off the streaming service entirely
never show it to anyone ever again but
anyway guys so that that doesn't happen
why don't you leave a like on this video
to let people know that you're enjoying
this as well subscribe to the channel
hit the notification Bell and uh Greg
you haven't you've got a message for us
today don't you oh yes we have a sponsor
that I I want to shout out can you leave
for a second I I would be honored my
feathered rejects today I've got a tail
waggingly good Scoop for you let's talk
about our sponsor bird dogs I'm wearing
their uncomfortable pants right now but
I'll so they have their shorts that'll
have you looking fetching these shorts
are no bird brainers my friends let me
show you they're designed to fit Slimmer
through the thigh and the leg giving you
a truly possum sculpted look they do
everything Lululemon does but with an
extra wag in their tail so say goodbye
to those rough cotton shorts bird dogs
fix that Mudder by creating their Cloud
knit fabric I mean come on it looks as
sharp as khaki but stretches like a dog
chasing its tail you're just gonna waste
them or fit without being you know leash
stricted got these puns going people
here's the cherry on top or should I say
the bird on the wire when you order from
bird dogs.com using my special code
rejects you'll fetch a free Yeti style
tumbler it's the perfect companion for
hydrating on your adventures
Grandpa's medicine so don't sit on the
perch my pals hurry over to birddogs.com
rejects to unleash the possum power of
these shorts and snag your free Yeti
style Tumblr trust me once you
experience the comfort and style you'll
be barking about bird dogs to all your
buddies they really are comfortable and
a lot of people want to know what are
some of the best ways to support the
channel one of the best ways to get
yourself some bird dogs by getting your
tail wagon head to birddogs.com rejects
now
you're awake
no news of nilfgaard or the girl and no
I didn't ask
that's the wrong question they will
string you up and then how would we have
these lovely daily chats
it's like you want to leave the show
we're going to give you no lines we're
going to paralyze you out of the show
you're sure this one deserves your help
let us decide that
same as we decided for you and the
square Hotel you've asked us to take in
backstory I will never command you milva
nor return you to the horrors of your
past backstory but you do owe a debt
backstory
[Laughter]
oh
[Applause]
yeah
this looks kind of soothing honestly
like a good burn I hope you guys start
working on his back soon I know seems
like the priority number one can we even
hold the damn sword are you gonna stop
him I've been telling him for months he
needs to think about himself and not
just Siri oh so you're not completely
useless but I was wrong what does he use
to get his chest hair that Perfect Trim
you really think you're ready to go find
a girl
[Music]
because you'd be dead now give him the
ten rings two years later
[Laughter]
geralt completes physical therapy
[Music]
please
infesting the wolf a series siding with
nilf God we're obliged to join you'd
fight for Neil Scott no not you guys I
love you guys you guys are the best
you know where this villager Force has
got us toad track him with your magic
what happened here
Evans he'll take all of us to reverse
the spell they deserve that
truly witchcraftian for a show that
actually has witches yeah actually it
feels like a like real witch
same
page
these alliances are always fluctuating I
feel like they secretly just like it
like that it would get boring otherwise
vilkaforts did it under your nose yes
anyone who brought them here if she had
looked after them properly at our Tusa
but with vilga forts he simply propped
up the mask save your sanctimony stop I
lost my hair in the process when are we
gonna remember my my brown locks my
Auburn locks you destroyed whomever just
so that visit me would finally see you
lurking in dextra's Shadows
we are partners and I can trust yeah
like I trusted vilgaforts
I love how vilga forces suddenly like
the big bang he's like the king man
we've been building through this whole
time
friggin vilga forts I liked old vilga
Forks I'm counting every minute Henry
cavill's not on
don't worry it's gonna make every minute
he is that much sweeter your rival in
aratuza helps secure what some may call
a victory
it did I got these bottles for that you
made someone someone who knows Andrea
from the inside someone who has no of
God's interests at heart so you're
proposing that I forgive your past sins
and return you to syndra yes yes I mean
you did it for kahir as Imperial
governor of centria and Francesca
can give her people the home they
deserve I must say from Jill and death
it becomes you
and thank you for recognizing that we
delivered what was promised the square
Hotel deserve peace
no
the school you tell they stay with us
they know the lads so well they are an
effective force in the north you mean a
dispensable one son of a [__]
kill him either they die fighting for us
or
all of you people's eye fighting to
survive
I'd follow this guy anywhere yeah he
really seems enlightened man he's
different he's like a Netflix CEO Dara
tuser is a pile of rocks the Brotherhood
has no brothers left and my brother's
dead enough ditch somewhere not you
sickest man oh
that our intelligence was right and our
plan was correct none of which stops my
people from doubting me
examples must be made we're not friends
anymore oh what's going to happen to him
I'm gonna execute him I know how much
you like Philippa
but someone's got to pay ah
that'll drive her back toward her
sister's here on thin ice Geeks
[Music]
lover ah perfectly eavesdropping
the symbolism
cool music yeah I start whipping that
sword around sure you still got it
should he still got it geralt
[Music]
training is fixing all of his injuries
he does do a good job selling the pain
and the anger and frustration there's
like some Dark Knight Rises flares to
this awesome
War evil overtaking while our hero is
healing his back
leg every day that I spend air is
another that's serious in danger
because you're hiding from the world
doesn't mean that I have to no uh tough
out hurt there for her man she's like
the only Asian person in this world no
it's lonely
[Applause]
I'm not scared to leave
oh I'm scared of what I do to them what
you do sounds necessary does it remind
you of someone you lost
it looks important
it reminds me of someone I killed
well we go way back yeah whatever that
did to you I hope they pay what if she's
in the wrong Daryl
hahaha
what if she's just crazy context is so
important yeah we haven't heard all
sides of the story you could have handed
series head over to the Kings on a
platter to win support but you didn't
motherly instincts your pain is my pay
codependency that's what John and I say
to each other before we read comments
feeling sorry for yourself and I think
vocal thoughts make you question who you
are I know you at your core the monolith
inside you everything that's been done
to me I've survived because of your
faith
you are the strongest force I've ever
known Archer core you are a beautiful
brunette woman
you ought to say a debris you are a
mother
we need you
I need you
found you some hair dye the service for
the novices
it's time
thank you
wow you too the acting is still so good
that the the editing of the scenes just
goes so fast yeah
hey we got [__] to do man it's the end
of the season there is a cost to this
magic and eventually we all must pay it
is not a gift
it is a trade you have to wield it a
little bit and that trade leads us to
Dark Places yeah that's a good look on
her yeah she's getting off the weight
now you has been the biggest Bright Spot
Of My Life
I know you will do great things my
daughter where is this going she can
suffer something
thank you
sometimes a flower
[Music]
flower
flower another call back bringing an
awful Circle and the thing it can do for
us
is dying
to say a no
[Music]
oh whoa what
who's gonna watch her bird now that's
tragic moments before it was a very
rousing
empowering speech that Jennifer was
giving yeah because it didn't work yeah
I want to let her be my motivational
speaker
track record is not serving you well
it's my fault and let me feed me
did your best man
[Music]
I'm so hungry
who do we have now you have each other I
will find Siri why is my just can't do
this without care hey they're more
unified than ever
oh the thoughts pay I'll make a mirror
pay too
[Music]
this might look a little different but I
wonder if in the healing process it's
gonna like cause some type of
regeneration thingy yeah
I feel like that's the the easiest
magical explanation yeah like he's not
gonna fully heal now
[Music]
promised a seamless transition I don't
know
someone's got to pay
oh who's it gonna be Gods is true you're
here you're alive
I'm a homosexual brother
I'm coming out I found me and helped get
me hurt your highness
I could not rest until I knew he was
safe he created a power vacuum in the
Brotherhood only we can feel the
Brotherhood is in shambles in the north
with it yes well I have a new plan for
redania I love the guy who plays the
king yeah I think he's so good
is a perfectly thankless role well I was
coming to ask you to uh let me go go
where in case you haven't noticed
there's a war going on and I'm no
helping it you'd be you've been trying
for years to find a purpose for me here
oh no he's found a purpose finally found
something that suits me
someone
and he needs my help he was there to say
I'm a homosexual pretty much I just need
to go be me visit me he's not wrong
the only demands accountability
[Music]
you can't pull this off in this state
man you got magic man
he's gonna just do it to himself I think
just television here it was my fault I
knew I could trust you with my life
oh I've made plans to protect us both
yeah no
all right
I was just saying
seems like the cleaning house and I'm
just thinking when it gets suspense beat
with dijkstra but I'll I'll trade him
for the game
I'm gonna take a mirror I'm Jessica you
can't take a deal from a plan that was
never real it could work bars what is
with these holy grounds and these
excessive amount of candles it must be
so hot
all humans are brutal he's a liar do you
know the Hedgehog may be killed and then
you try to set me up for it
and I kind of took credit but I didn't
actually do it and then he keeps rodania
try to manipulate you our child and you
knew
uh Amir was coming to sintra
and I had to gain his favor
and so I told him that your baby your
baby was
gone there's a way of keeping you here
keep us fighting I can't undo what I've
done
let's get oh yeah deserves to suffer
just as you have you do not get to cry I
don't this will be the Oscar clip the
Emmy clip he does not know the meaning
of suffering but he will and so will you
yeah Boogie
oh my God it only took the last like 20
minutes of season three to finally care
about her
things are really cooking now G
it's gonna be a great last Act of the
episode
you're the king now radovid oh the
brother will suspect how did this happen
oh God we'll find out whoever is
responsible will be made to pay we must
move quickly our enemies will capitalize
on this tragedy say we are leaderless
she changed her hair fast I know she's
got so many great Styles it's our great
Fortune radovid is back safely Mighty of
heart and spirit yep take it Long Live
King
you know there's a time and a place yeah
I know maybe not right in front of the
Dead bro Over My Dead Body
[Music]
and and bummer about King vismir
really poor timing maybe she was
sleeping with that girl just to use her
yeah I brought us back here to make good
on the promise of never letting the
Salvation our Chooser is gone the future
of magic has never been more unstable
but it lies in your hands Sisterhood
rise the most dangerous Mage we've ever
seen has the most powerful Source this
continent has ever known we need to
eliminate vocaforts yes we know
God
I feel like they've been
essentially repeating
just in different lines yeah a little
bit but in different places the subject
and with different people now dead it's
all the same never interrupt an artist
when he is in a state of numinous flow
oh my god when I found my own people
I thought I'd recovered what I'd lost
but they agreed
to help the White Flame start at War so
I ran and so far
[Music]
too Brooklyn Forest this hatred
it'll kill me yes it will oh after being
off screen for 15 minutes he's back
she was the first person that I ever
felt safe with
tell her I forgive her and that I'm
sorry
good good I've been waiting for that hey
I'll be excited for his Redemption don't
worry itching for that I'm in your
corner Dara everyone being as
powerfulness
[Music]
pretty cool one more girl chemistry
sequences yeah man-made yes girl YouTube
mate we have to cook
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you'd be dead now
bring the Cajun girl with you yeah the
one with the backstory who owes you some
stuff yeah Nova subplot
[Applause]
[Music]
roll music yeah we're gonna get like a
heavy version of one of you ask your
songs for the end credits Henry cavill's
barely been in these last three episodes
this episode series barely fitted it's
as if he already left
an auspicious day my Lord
whoa what happened to your
face my friend
build a face get it have you heard of an
eye patch
vilga Fury
is hereby endowed with the title of
Duchess of Rowan and himla oh there's
going to be a scene of like come with me
Siri yeah but is it a real Siri or is it
another fake Siri welcome home you know
where you belong
it's a pleasure Your Grace I thought
Liam Hemsworth was going to come to this
show what's going on baby they're
changing everyone big switch
oh boy wait is she the same one from the
few episodes ago who thought she was
Siri I think it's a different one but
I'm not 100 I know we've seen that girl
before I just don't remember which one
nice to see you finally awake
you want to get out of here yeah
[Laughter]
she's been here before Haley heard of
him one of the rats at the barn the rats
they are rats
oh wow that's the wind enough God's been
searching for you're as useless as a
unicorn she's not more than more than
what's between her legs the way you
think this is what's happening inside
the buildings on Pirates of the
Caribbean I like that shot of Siri
studying how he was listening to see if
he's like tempted At All by this
information
this [__] is Highborn oh there it is
yeah jump on it she told you she was
hungry kid this guy's cool the rat is
mine touch him again I'll plunge this
blade Through Your Eyes
the rat's in the white wolf you get it
show me show me boys come on how did she
get it
the rats these are the rats the Rat Pack
[Applause]
turning up that frame rate
I knew you were alive you little [__]
obviously done okay
these cool Street rats man yeah I'm
excited to spend the last five minutes
with us yeah that's a cool swashbuckling
vibe to them I like it yeah
cool
they know how to throw down on a fight
boy
oh nice
hey trouble
make it double how about a fair fire
kick his ass sea bass prove you're worth
Siri let's see how you do against a
human
[Music]
so my daddy girl taught you you're
finally with people your own age join
the ravagers Gamora oh she's gonna do
this like one one hit she's gonna be one
slice she's gonna like bisect him up the
center
she's playing with him
[Music]
whoa yeah good job kid I will say this
this season really has drastically made
me care more about Siri I'm way more
interested in her development and how
she's coming to her own a lot more I
think her even that last episode I think
really
added to it yeah no she's like the most
intriguing part down yeah I know she has
set up the character she's my she's the
most one I'm most into when we cut to
her that's got to be another way around
not for days take this good man on you
go quid pro quo you want to get through
your pay
that looks nice
hold on uh
for your troubles
oh is that in the past go we were
wandering through boundless Fields
towards an obelisk curve with names of
the Dead a woman with cold blue eyes
who's following you don't make a
difference geralt
Carol we need to get to Siri just keep
witching geralt
why don't you let the girl in her family
go face off
or maybe I'll take her home and see what
you she can be put to not dude you're
just saying the worst things to finally
be afraid
yeah geralt
you'd always been afraid until now
because she's taking everything from you
great shot so taking the fear you're
ouch these Hot Head angles
neutrality be damned
we are no longer afraid
goddamn right take on the whole Army's
worth whole battalion
there's some Henry Cavill for you
oh
gnarly
[Music]
him
oh my God finally
bitching you'd be dead
I know
I'll be dead now
missed one
no I didn't
Save The Best For Last oh yeah that's
why I just punched you in the face
you managed to get to know God before I
do
you too
come here
I will free Siri
oh he is declaring daddy girl man family
is the true Elixir we have a side quest
[Music]
Now give me coins so you can pass yeah
I'm still gonna pay this guy
and I will make sure this is safe world
for her to return to
[Music]
still left it behind yeah is this like a
Celtic House of the Rising Sun but we
will be the last to fall all my love
[Music]
cool is it about to end it feels like
it's about to end
with them just riding off into the next
adventure
no transition in sight we gotta go is
she alone she can use a sword what's
your name
join the rats come on I'm a rat call me
falcon
[Music]
new song
you gotta be [__] kidding me
that is the final episode for Henry
Cavill apparently that's that's what I'm
told that's what we have been told that
is [__]
that is very strange that is [__] it
feels nothing at all like there's about
to be a major casting change nah man
this just reeks of behind the scenes
troubles yeah yeah it really does every
rumor I've heard I feel like is true now
man God they didn't even like give a
[__] to make it a send-off that is not a
send-off that's the promise he's barely
in this episode he's barely I mean he's
like obviously barely in the last one
too
oh man this is this is the direction I
promise of more geralt yaskir and milva
Adventures like it's it's not a bad
episode I I don't think it's a bad
episode I don't think it's like flawless
I don't think it it's fantastic or
anything but there's definitely things I
really liked about this episode
okay but then you do got to separate the
context of this is also Henry cavill's
last episode uh as geralt and just
knowing how absent he was from the
screen time in the last three episodes
and they still use him as the main
advertisement he is still the titular
character yeah he's The Witcher
oh boy I maybe maybe it was an attempt
to go he's not returning so we really
got to put focus on these other plot
lines
that way the audience is really invested
in in you know these other storylines
that they'll want to return for season
four
but you know that's not where people's
heads are at right now come on come on I
know there are people obviously there
are people who love all the story lines
who are very much have their hearts
vested into all these other ones of
course of course
everyone is also very much well aware
and it also kind of just you know speaks
a little bit towards that fact of how uh
out of touch the writer the the show
Runners uh have been with uh the
audience
so you know I think regardless of
whatever [__] you got with Henry Cavill
I'm like you got to be of service in
this moment man this is a terrible
send-off this is not even remotely close
what do you think we're just gonna walk
in like acting like business as usual
next season and be like all of a sudden
yeah did you shoot something else with
Henry Cavill That You're Gonna Save till
the beginning of next season for some
kind of sequence that directly explains
this or is he just gonna show back up as
Liam Hemsworth and you're just gonna is
the seamless transition just that we
will never acknowledge it and we're just
going to keep going as if nothing
happened yeah barely a scene with
yennefer no scene with Siri no no yeah
no real proper send-off oh God is I feel
like I could just kind of
lament my emotions about that this
entire time not even talk about anything
else that happened I mean yeah because
there's a lot that happened there but
God damn that is [__] it is [__] it is
this episode has two responsibilities it
has the sending off of Henry Cavill as
geralt and then everything else you know
yeah I think with the send-off what they
were attempting to do was tie it back
into the first episode of you know
geralt where you know we obviously had
Henry Cavill there him literally leaving
uh the the approach thing yeah whatever
that is behind uh as symbolic of saying
goodbye to the past with with this with
this version of geralt I feel like that
was the attempt to do that sure not
enough
so it's so minimal it is such a small
it's it it and uh it's not even a line
between subtle and Grand you know it is
no it's just like a nice thematic thing
I'm glad they paid attention to but like
as the rest of it postures as if it is
just business as usual and that he did
just recover and is gonna be you know
out upon many more an adventure or
whatever oh God man because they really
they've really
really diminished his screen time well
yeah obnoxiously barely yeah it is very
strange and whenever he is on screen
most of the dialogue comes back to the
same stuff about like oh you just all
about your family man that family is
really giving you a lot of a lot of
reason to live man oh hey your family's
in danger you gotta go fight for her
we'll we'll get back together you gotta
go find Siri find Siri geralt Siri
geralt Siri like I don't know I it's
that was so awful part of me was more
open to the idea of what it looked I I
made peace at a certain point in the
episode I was like okay so maybe we
won't get him back kicking ass like we
did at one point but maybe yeah they'll
do something where this healing process
is painful and will have some kind of
character thing that needs to be let go
of and in that process he will transform
in this regeneration into Liam Hemsworth
and like part of me was like okay if
they're gonna commit to that then fine I
could be open to that but then they I
kind of like give you your cake in an
attempt to let you eat it too because
then he comes back and he does the whole
badass like I'm making my own potion
thing and then he like levels that whole
Battalion of of uh you know soldiers and
whatnot and it's like they give you like
one last badass fight to like I feel
like
who cares at this voice fight scene well
yeah it's like they gave you a bunch of
stuff
but none of which like coalesce or
harmonize with each other they feel like
disjointed and stuff and so yeah like
it's it's such a strange his Arc has
already been well established yeah of of
who he has art into he's a family man
that's all he is he is I get it like
yeah I don't want to harp The Fast and
Furious forever but it does feel like
they did kind of mimify that part of the
character or at least just rest most
everything on that yeah he's become a
softy yeah I like you yaskir you're my
best friend Jennifer I love you and Siri
I'm a Daddy to you and I get kick ass
once in a while when I have to
I don't like anybody else so when
anybody else around I could kick ass
sometimes but yeah maybe they did shoot
something additional for them to use or
they're just going to cut to us Liam
Hemsworth um but okay uh I I think that
geralt's storyline here uh while
personal for the most part for the
entirety of the Season uh I I I did love
how he like like my favorite moments
where geralt are still the end of volume
my mind actually flashes too when he
just lets it out to yennefer that he
loves her that felt like yeah yeah that
felt like the climax of his character
yeah that to me that was complete there
and then here I guess is the pie
um so yeah okay there's that God I I am
so like how can I just focus on the
episode now okay that is such a that is
such crap well I was getting so worried
when I was I was just getting so worried
we're
they would cut to him for like a minute
and then they'd be gone for 10 minutes
then he's back for a minute then he's
gone for like 10 minutes again yeah it
was that was just the structure of this
episode
that is uh that that is that is this
really bothersome man that really
bothers me yeah it's odd it no it just
it is awesome
like he really is it seems like so so on
it's such a weird thing to have an actor
so embroiled in this kind of situation
across so many different planes of of
entertainment yeah and uh yeah I don't
know it is one of those things I think
you're right that just does when you see
it make you wonder because they've been
talking about it you know in the lead up
to the season no no it's gonna make
sense it's gonna be totally smooth and
they know people are they obviously know
this on everybody's mind everyone's
anticipating this and so uh they I don't
know just the promise of more like it
ends on the promise of more it ends in
the promise of of uh of her from Shang
Chi and him and yaski are going out on
more Adventures yeah and even their like
Bromance over this as you know not been
as engaged or whatever I don't know
um
all right well I think we've made it
really clear how we feel there so good
send off loved Henry oh man
um
and I mean I don't know honestly I just
don't care enough to return to this show
I I just don't like I I I my interest in
most of these story lines just has felt
like diminishing returns the more this
goes on I I care about very few things
in in this show now it's not even just
the Henry cow it's really not the Henry
Cavill thing
well I I think we can talk about the
things that I that we did like
um I mean I don't know if you like more
than me but we'll see
I really I really like what they've
developed with Siri that's been my
biggest takeaway yeah uh out of what
they did to Henry Cavill my biggest
takeaway is
before it was like just you know Henry
Cavill yennefer and Siri was always an
important part of the story and I always
cared about the interactions that others
would have off like the the importance
of her storyline but Siri the character
she's never been a bad eye for never
remembering the actress's name
I've never thought that uh and I know if
some people really love her her
storyline I love her and like while I've
always thought she was good I just never
personally really gravitated towards her
character so much as a Solo character to
be watching and with the last episode
and then this one she's on her own she's
away from the main story lines you know
as her story is developing and I'm sure
there's some wonderful Easter egg there
with that name drop that she decides to
go by oh yeah do you know I have no idea
what the hell it is we didn't read the
books play the game so I don't know
significant
that's amazing uh cool and I really do
love how they've developed her character
because yeah when they do cut to her
very late into the episode and she's
tied up and everything and just like the
the performance that she carries in her
eyes as she's tied up
it did hit me right in that moment like
oh [__] I really love what they've done
with her she's like I I noticed like I
really want to be here right now with
her I'm not thinking about anything else
I'm not thinking about cut to anything
else I'm really interested right now in
what's going on because it's her yeah so
that was a big Telltale sign to me of
okay I love what they've done with her
100 that's grown to me that's grown
really nicely because at the beginning
of the show I was in a similar position
to you where I was like yeah this stuff
is interesting enough when it's on
screen I'm not super invested in Syria
and what her Stakes are one way or the
other however
just the more yeah she has been
developed through her bonding with
geralt and Yen and all that stuff and
yeah and come into her own and such and
her you know just acting has grown you
know as she has grown on this and I
think in some ways it's nicest pitched
to capture a lot of magic with her
because she's coming of age in real life
as this character is also coming of age
uh and so yeah like I I think they've
made that stuff some of the most
interesting I actually care about her
Stakes the the weird intersection of
everyone's need to use her for some
purpose or that means to her her you
know aspirations of being a Witcher and
a Mage and all that stuff like that's
actually like quite like if I was
compelled to return it would be to find
out mostly about her journey because
yeah she doesn't feel like I think
successfully she feels like a propulsive
and engaged part of the story whereas
certain characters who I really like
feel like perfunctory characters that
they're trying to keep around yeah um
but yeah and I think her performances
are really great and I liked her action
scene there at the end a lot uh and her
you know portrayal of of just the weird
struggle of like all these harsh things
she's having to do and even though we've
dogged on her over the season for you
know the times when it's like lay low
Siri and she's like going out and
causing a ruckus or whatever like I've
always been yeah pretty compelled by and
enjoying watching her yeah uh and I feel
like of all of our main characters hers
is the most substantively written
storyline
Jennifer I always have loved uh I I've
always loved Jennifer and you know the
actress
um oh my God
alotra she's amazing regardless I think
uh she's she's amazing
and I I really love I I just love the
aura and the vibe of the witches uh when
they really feel like witches yes you
know the my favorite Parts is the
convent is that the word fruit Covenant
Covenant guy keep saying the wrong uh
Covenant Kevin
yeah forgive me guys cousin of witches
um sleep schedule way off words
vocabulary even more diminishing before
the full moon
um yeah but yeah when they're in
procession and they've got the candles
and they're chanting and they're really
forming like a a real cover like it's
been a Brotherhood it's been a
Brotherhood of sorcerers for a long time
with like a lot of female Mages that's
never felt like witches it's never truly
felt like witchcraft yeah so now having
this like Sisterhood they haven't named
it that but you know what appears to be
that arising does give it this like
really fun cool yeah especially witchy
Druid like aesthetic and I I really love
that and
while I think the aesthetic was very
appealing and the the capturing of the
whole mood was appealing I did feel like
the scenes in and of themselves were
always like
get your [__] together we gotta kill
vilgavors yeah we're all suffering and
we're all grieving and we're all just
sort of like hey can't we just get it
together ah you know yeah we got I
thought every scene ended with we're
gonna rise up but another time they cut
back to them they're they're sad and it
ends with we gotta rise up yeah I
thought before it's just getting closer
that we did this
yeah yeah totally um so yeah I thought
the writing of that in particular was
not the strongest the the the uh stuff
um I'm still kind of processing that in
a better episode I think this that could
have been handled like the choice for
what happens with their character
totally makes sense uh and and it does
show just how
how destroyed because she's like the
leader you know and how destroyed
everything really is and how does Sheila
Fordson so close and well it shows the
hopelessness of their situation yeah but
yet I don't really feel the hopelessness
of their situation because this show is
asking me to care about a billion
different story lines well it's right
and like you pointed out the editing
like it does feel like it's chop
chopping its way along like yes it
should have been happening in a better
story should have happened in a better
episode you know because it's like it's
one of many billion things that happened
in this one episode well this feels like
a season that could be like 10 episodes
if you're really gonna do all this off
sending and and stuff like that I don't
know yeah five and three I get it for
where they split the story it makes
sense but at the same time I don't know
there's just yeah a lot that they could
have like the this episode was packed
with a lot of stuff but the problem is
that it highlights the time you're
spending away from Henry Cavill and it
could have been better proportion maybe
in other ways but yeah but yeah the
hopping uh from all that and then you
have like all this stuff with like
dijkstra and Philippa and rodania yeah
oh God yeah uh the king who like I like
the king I like the king's performance
when he was with the brother I was like
you know I love the brother I think he's
been a great addition to the show yeah
he's been terrific I think he's been
yeah that's something the turn with him
is intriguing I I thought he's been
consistently really appealing to watch
and the king I really like too he feels
very natural he's got just the right
amount to feel like arrogant pompous guy
who's in a royalty position kind of dumb
but also you can see how he takes
command you know like I really liked
when he's with
terrible names
what does he specifically say to him
don't handle me or something like that
yeah like I know what you're trying to
like the way he says that you know like
oh he shows that he is he's smart know
what you do to me a lot of the time yeah
yeah what your job is and that you're
good at it yeah at the end of the day he
is smart and you see how he is a king
despite how sniveling he is and I really
I think his his acting is just so good
so it bummed me out when he died because
he brings such life to that character
and it's yeah it's a hard one to do
without being a complete cartoon yes I
really liked him so it bummed me out
when he when he died
um
character
I don't know I mean the show sheep's
trying to tell me he's like really smart
but he just seems like progressively
weak as as a character as he keeps going
yeah and I mean maybe I gotta go back
and re-watch but it just didn't feel
like the whole you wanna I think feel
with that character like what he says is
kind of true that like yes there's a
certain element of luck involved with
all of our machinations and even though
it didn't go in our favor this time we
still got some type of benefit out of
the situation it does kind of feel like
hey you had a vague plan and you walked
in and uh hit the fan yeah yeah and you
shot your your shot but uh you know
the fact that he gave him one more
chance I was like he could easily just
been like no like we've you've cost me
too much now we're done here yeah that
was a bummer I mean it's like it's cool
for uh Philippa I think her name is like
it's cool for her dynamic because she's
really the one pulling all the strings
yeah but yeah
um I guess uh uh visit me wasn't so
smart after all
I gotta tell you man uh I think one of
the most disappointing parts of this
season is everything to do with white
flame
um that dude is just not as interesting
as the season finale set him up to be
well he's just always like chilling at
the Capitol like in his you know
Chambers just like giving people
Redemption and sending them out on
missions it's all the all the scenes
they've given him
have not felt in anything unique they
feel as generic and by the numbers as
you'd expect when you have such an
interesting setup for this guy with with
knowing his introduction knowing his
backstory well they're giving him like
the bad guy treatment when I feel like
we could be really spending time
watching this guy Rule and getting like
a complicated portrait of what his you
know real out in the open Agenda is yeah
I don't I don't care about him uh that
is such a great Cliffhanger with him in
the last season and then here they have
made the interest level on him just go
down so much
uh boring and uh that we did not see
kahir thank God never really liked him
um uh I like you
okay
I fell for uh uh frangela and Francesca
is that her name the elf lady I I I like
their ultimate ending scene the scene
most of the time I mean I like fringeal
for the most part I do
um but the elf lady yeah I'm like oh
finally she gets one true like I liked I
liked her in the battle when her brother
died and all and she looked cool and
whatever when she's all smeared in blood
but her actual but she she's only really
to me got one good scene here in the
season where I'm like oh you're finally
an interesting character character yeah
I'm just yeah Warrior or whatever not
just a symbol well there are everyone's
just given just that I think the
dialogue has gone so downhill well yeah
I mean yeah it's felt very repetitive in
certain aspects and then other aspects
they just pull in I don't know it's
weird like the language the voice of the
show to my ear has changed each season
and this feels the least sort of
immersed in what I associate with I
don't know that first impression of
season one feeling a bit more again I
keep coming back to the phrase literary
the term literary because it used to
feel like this was ripped out of a book
and now it feels like a cool action you
know fantasy thing this feels like
Wikipedia the movie sure sure yeah yeah
yeah no exactly because that's about as
much meat as you get on a lot of these
characters or or not even Wikipedia it's
like every episode is a Wikipedia it's
more it's more close notes it's more
akin to um reading of fandom wire page
where you you want to know what happens
in an episode yeah and that's what a lot
of it feels like uh it it would would
intermittently like a really compelling
scene that comes in the form of your
interest in the characters uh I kind of
like archery Asian lady from sunshi
I like her
uh she's got Charisma so I I like her
and they were shows obviously we don't
have time to dive into your backstory so
it was just wonderful let's give some
quick little hints that we accepted you
here you have an origin where you lost
stuff and you owe us yeah we're gonna
hold that over your head forever more
details to come yeah so I liked her and
I I did feel like
the bummer part of it and I made the
joke early on the bummer part of it is
when it is yaskir and uh geralt and her
in the end I was like yeah they are a
good Trio I I like them I like them as a
trio and now I gotta adjust my brain to
Liam Hemsworth if I want to watch the
next season but
man I I I I I I I just don't care and a
lot of this stuff is like even when it
comes to the king who we liked
even for the qualities of the acting of
dijkstra and the Mage and the Mages even
the Mages you know
even there I
I
I can everything we're talking about I
can appreciate I can definitely pinpoint
things to appreciate about it but if
we're talking about is my heart and soul
truly uh invested or can't give a [__]
while watching it to the point where I'm
like emotionally enthralled or pulled in
to the degree where not one part of me
is checking out
I'm not gonna lie to you I'm totally
like like I really got nothing going on
here but most of the times there's
really nothing happening in my heart uh
for for most of this it's not even
Josiah's death it's like oh bummer yeah
because things move I'm willing to move
on right now let's get a move on here
because yeah we're being whisked along
to the next plot line yeah yeah it's
it's a bummer because I feel like this
show and especially the season to me is
marked by again all the potential that's
like here on screen there's so much that
they have working for them and I think
spending time in this world is really
fun the sets and the effects that bring
the world to life or for the most part
beautiful to look at oh sorry hold
there's a lot of sweeping camera work
and some definitely fights Great
Performances all that stuff costumes
everything but yeah
experience of experiencing the story
just feels like it's become increasingly
sort of like a mess and and yeah it's
like this has felt more sort of
like uh yeah as sort of not not quite
like a blockbuster but some sort of like
fantasy light thing that has all the
production values that you want but
there's just yeah isn't going
I don't know it's just not making it
feel like you're living in this world as
much as it used to and it's also
I don't know for me as a monster fan
kind of feel like it is really
struggling to maintain that aspect of
the show which like like which shirt
that's way gone yeah and I feel like The
Witcher lifestyle The Witcher vocation
such as it is and what we've seen about
with like the fall of care morning like
like the state that that's in I feel
like there's lots you could do with
the witchers of the world they introduce
so many different storylines and then
the story lines are continuing or
they're getting less and less
interesting it feels like they should
have spread all this over more seasons
you know it's like like this all feels
like it should have been happening at
like season four or five or something
like that and then let you know this is
weak ass Cliffhanger I gotta say this is
a terrible Cliffhanger well no it it's
weird it feels like I get why they split
this chunk the way it did but the
overall season feels like it is the
first half of something yeah I think the
Cliffhanger is like what was the
Cliffhanger last one wild Hunt oh [__]
wild Hunt is on and here is Dooney yeah
yeah
um yeah and the wild hunters
barely a smoking topic of conversation
here like and like that was at least wow
it was gonna be crazy next season and
and it'd be nice maybe the name she
drops has something to do with it
because she's embracing chaos magic
that's a guess I have no idea I'm sure I
could Google it I'll find out but uh
this this Cliffhanger like while I love
uh everything they have done with Siri
and while I feel like she's become out
of all the characters
she's become my favorite yeah of them
all yeah I I I still I'm like well yeah
I mean you've you've essentially got her
further away from the main plot now that
she's off with these guys I mean they'll
take their time more in the future like
it's weird I am excited like that was a
cool Prospect I'm like yeah these I like
the first guy that they introduce you to
and then seeing them all fight you know
the tavern full of guys like yeah I was
like cool well I'll see Siri like travel
around with these dudes for a while
before you know getting anywhere near
the Emir plot again but you need like a
strong central core Focus it's family
you need a strong central core Focus if
you look at many of our greatest
um which I you know would be that they
want Siri and we gotta beat nilfgaard
right yeah but for some reason it still
feels so messy it still feels all over
the place but if you look at like our
great fantasy films you know the Harry
Potter movies uh Lord of the Rings like
Lord of the Rings is a great example of
it is it's like as many storylines as
many characters as you're cutting around
to in as much GI photography as you're
going around to it's all centering back
to Sauron in the ring and you got to
make sure he doesn't get that ring you
know that he's Rising that it's like a
real simple you need that you need that
simple thing to centralize and ground
the comp the complicated aspects well
because that'll yeah and that is not
really great it's like yeah I can say it
nilfgaard White Flame you know but for
some reason I'm like I still feel like
this is all over the place I still feel
like I need to go wait wait hold on can
I get this all on like a piece of paper
in front of me so that I can fill in the
blanks for myself yeah you need a strong
central Focus that you could always come
back to to keep everything like zeroed
in to keep it from becoming chaos it
feels a little bit like chaos now and
it's like you need that strong central
point so that you can both delve out the
plot points when you need to and do
Exposition but also so that you can sell
just living and traveling and feel
feeling the actual you know it's a time
very much removed from now and I think
it's important in these things to show
that and I think especially in these
later like this season certainly doesn't
feel like it takes much time to get
anywhere or like there's any much
distance between things really or even
when Game of Thrones was great you know
they would be all over the place there
would be a lot to keep up with it would
be totally like so much and it wasn't as
a simplified Focus they would kind of
have a simple focus of like who's the
main you know computer hierarchy so
you've got you know there's lots of
unrested between the houses the
Lannisters are your big big problem and
then you've got the white walkers over
here that's like your problem outside of
everything and they're building to that
and they did a great job per season as
establishing what the per storyline what
the main things were to focus and worry
about from protagonist antagonist you
know so I and I think that this this
just doesn't have that it it is it's
just a big zigzag yeah of of like man
they keep changing up these plots and
then even even like with the brother
becoming King like oh I I don't even
it's all happening so fast everything's
just has
Tumbleweed and you'll have certain
episodes too where it's like you'll be
hopping around a lot and then you'll
take a break and you'll do like an
interlude where it's like way slower
than everything else and and like that
last episode was just like mostly in the
desert yeah and I'm like this is cool
but it's not amounting to as much as
this show-stopping moment seems to think
it like it would Merit and I don't want
to feel like every time Witcher comes
back I gotta re-watch all of Witcher in
order to like try to understand like
what's happening you know yeah and I
think there is something to be said for
the fact that like when these things are
cooking you can not get every last thing
but get enough to form strong
associations so that hey if a name is
confusing at least you have like a good
idea of who's who when you see them and
what the you know major conflicts are
and I feel like yeah in a show this show
has been a lot more of like wait wait
hold on I gotta keep track of this stuff
rather than like they're helping me form
those associations emotionally yeah you
know especially as we've gotten deeper
into this
um anyway guys I did not like this
season oh yeah overall like I like stuff
about it obviously I think as a whole I
will remember this as the one that made
me go I don't think I want to watch this
show anymore
um so yeah I and it is not have anything
to do with like standing for Henry
Cavill or something like that even
though I obviously
vehemently and very much not satisfied
in any close capacity he's been great as
this character and especially these last
three episodes like not to say that he
wasn't invested but even his presences
don't feel very punctuated by much and
he's been you know decommissioned it
feels like yeah the crescendo was when
they went to the ball together in the
end of the first volume of season three
yeah so as a season overall though I
thought it was very it had very minimal
impact and it was a bit of a a chore
sometimes just keeping my eyes on the
screen
um and so yeah while there was things to
appreciate for sure which I we have
covered uh I I overall I am I I don't
think I unless there's like just the
most insane word of mouth oh my God
why did they put Liam in to begin with
unless there's a craziest Word of Mouth
uh I'm not making plans right now to
watch uh season four
um unless the Word of Mouth from
audiences is so good I'm looking more at
like what our audience is saying sure
and unless that is great
um then yeah I I have no interest right
now
uh and know that we declared this early
on before all you guys start coming at
us going why aren't you reacting to
season four wheelers
no rage watches yeah leave your thoughts
Down Below guys on what you guys thought
of The Witcher season three be very
curious to know
um leave a like and thank you so much
for being here and we will talk with you
all soon
but before we go let's shout out some
patrons
Jacob Neptune I'd give him a left nut
Christian Neal I'd kneel before you Ryan
Smith I'd poop with the door closed for
you Kevin Meek let's let's go take a
long walk on the beach Adrian Tim's I'd
let you have a fry real nagas you can
you can copy my math homework it's cool
Jonathan May uh I love your body nothing
is more clear than the greatness of
Heather gear I will never snitch on yui
and Simon no matter how horrible it gets
for the last time Songhai Glover it's
okay you can just have my kidney Kaylee
King I don't know why we don't do
karaoke together more often I got a bone
to pick with you Alan Ling you know get
over here we'll settle this Logan your
uh flies down see Kelsey the key to a
good fried egg is to cook it slowly Cara
someone broke into your car last night
and I did nothing when I saw it happen
ericon's 39 I can't wait to slather you
in baby oil
no one said you were racist it just it
just sounded racist when you said it why
yes Nick X I do know how to change a
tire and I can show you as well hey
Dijon if that's the hill you want to die
I'm so be it I mean Kevin Spacey doesn't
have as many supporters these days
Juan Longoria you're the Don Juana my
Demarco
Cliff Rodriguez just submit your script
now no one's pitching them right now
Arturo Malian Higginbotham Jr oh my God
I I want to just live on your estate and
be your servant go Nation no one has to
know that I walked in on you touching
yourself so stop broadcasting it please
Lorenzo Baxter you dog you hey
differently saying um did you share my
Max password with someone because uh
having a hard time logging in I swear
Marco Tunstall I'll get you the money I
just need a few more days it's coming
all right give me a chance all right
Lauren the drop off point
it's gonna be right in front of the
Hooters
I like that store
simply faded nothing's ever that simple
with you but that's why I like you
you're complex sj94 if you didn't get
tested how's anyone supposed to know
that it came from you Justin Martin look
you've had enough I'm cutting you off
now okay Rosie what you want to do is
find a home buy it and then you can rent
it out that way you can earn the equity
over the course of several years on your
property
that's just good advice listen Colin you
got you gotta choose last name I know
it's open-ended and you like the options
but come on man it's time to pick one
Philip Smith people are starting to
become suspicious
of what the J stands for I don't want to
say what people think the J stands for
but it rhymes with coup
Jen Smith we need more of that Moxie
around here you got the job you're hired
I think the outfit was revealing Melody
I think it showed courage
certainly it did you are a brave brave
soul and all of you are all of you who
support us each month with your love and
your enthusiasm never stop never
stopping
guys thanks for being the life's blood
of the recheck Nation the truest of the
true citizens
stay Pleasant we'll catch you next month